on prime crime it's the killing that
left a family and community without
answers are you confident that this case
will be solved no
but when all roads lead to one man our
plan all along was to catch him off
guard did you murder someone that named
jerry test the dna
jerry
test the dna
this cold case starts to heat up did you
ever ask the defendant directly if he
committed the crime yes i did
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most
high-profile and memorable true crime
cases our next story is about a killing
that remained unsolved for almost four
decades
december 20th
1979 cedar rapids iowa
a time of joy in holiday festivities was
shattered by a grisly discovery outside
of the popular westdell mall
during this period of time particularly
in a town where this took place
they were not
used to
having crimes that occurred
with this level of violence
eighteen-year-old michelle martinko was
found dead inside of her family's buick
parked in the mall's lot
she was found
slumped over
the passenger side she had absolutely
been brutalized
with
a sharp instrument we're talking about
multiple stabbing injuries now she had
over 20 stab injuries and a lot of these
were centered
around her face
well we got the call about six o'clock
in the morning from my mother she told
us in in words that you could almost not
understand that my sister had been
murdered
it was
beyond awful
to imagine that my sister had been
stabbed to death while christmas
shopping was just unthinkable
any motives at all can you can you think
of any reason why anyone want to kill
her
no from what our understanding is a
a very nice young lady it's a sad
situation
we have no idea at this point
there's actual smeared glove prints and
those are on the steering wheel the gear
shift and also the lights that initial
crime scene showing that there was no
robbery her purse was there was
undisturbed her packages were there
completely undisturbed that it was just
a killing
the crime scene though did tell
authorities something
as the investigators made their way
around the vehicle
they didn't find any blood outside of
the vehicle
whatever happened
was contained within this small space
there's indications that she had
injuries on her hands her arms defensive
motion so she had an awareness of what
was happening to her at that moment in
time
so the original investigation in 1979
was a really straightforward
investigation they collected
you know the evidence at the crime scene
and interviewed all of michelle's
friends and any logical suspects they
could come up with at the time it wasn't
the stone ages but they did have limited
forensic
technology they could work with
in the mid 80s it was reinvestigated by
the iowa department of criminal
investigation they sort of started from
scratch again
but in 1985 nothing had really changed
and they came to the same conclusion is
that we don't have any one particular
suspect
are you confident that this case will be
solved no
no i'm not
the murder of michelle martinko remained
an unsolved case for decades
no answers
no closure
but then over 20 years later a clue
back in 2006 the case was reopened by a
cold case investigator that investigator
happened upon a blood sample
and he took the dna and put it into the
coda system which is a national dna data
bank
unfortunately
at that moment tom
they didn't get hit and it would take
several more years
finally they were able to take this
blood and turn the blood over to an
individual that could do dna phenotyping
phenotyping gives you a physical
appearance of an individual based upon
their genetic
mapping they were able to come up with a
new composite
and that would ultimately bring
investigator matt denlinger to a new
technology that has since changed
criminal law ged match was
brought to my attention by parabon they
explained to me that it was a online
open database that people had
contributed their dna samples
we had to find some very distant
relatives and then find a common
ancestor with the dna that was from the
scene
from that common ancestor to look at all
of the descendants
and when we came back with an answer of
a second cousin once removed
was our our match
to me that was it was a game changer
authorities narrowed down their suspect
list to one man and after matching his
dna from a straw he had thrown away to
the blood found on michelle martinko's
dress law enforcement believe they
finally had the killer
jerry lynn burns
after we identified jerry as our suspect
we found an incredibly limited amount of
information in 1979 he had a couple of
children he was a traveling salesman he
had a super limited criminal history
um and there was nothing about him that
was screaming kill her
now it was time to actually confront
burns and see how he would react
we had planned this uh you know where
are we going to interview
our suspect and so we decided we were
going to settle on his office we wanted
to make sure that he was away from his
wife
and we were going to try to get him
alone
and and that's that's exactly what
happened
hey how are you today
jerry my name's matt
nice to meet you nice to meet you hey
i'm with the cedar rapids police
department oh yeah this is jd hi uh hey
he's at me
hey can we chat with you for a second
about a case we're working on sure
do police though have the right man
up next it's all about what burns says
or maybe
doesn't say
stay with us
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate lawn crime in the
channel guide and for only 1.99 a month
you can add the network to your bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
we're following up on an old case i
don't know if you've heard in the news
at all it's a homicide that happened at
westdale mall
michelle marteco is that something
you've ever heard of yeah
on december 19 2018 iowa investigator
matt denlinger is interviewing 64 year
old jerry burns about the unsolved
murder of michelle martinko an 18 year
old young woman found stabbed to death
in her family's car back in 1979
what do you remember hearing about it
this it was a big deal
a big deal i mean do you remember what
happened
not exactly
not only is burns surprised by
denlinger's visit but little does he
know that law enforcement have already
matched his dna taken from a discarded
straw to blood found at the crime scene
our plan all along was to catch him off
guard not give him any uh forewarning
that we're coming and not giving
any opportunity to think of answers to
potential questions
we had an article run in the paper the
other day and so we just got a bunch of
new leads and stuff like that people
calling in giving us tips and whatnot
and stuff like that well long story
short your name came up
strange yeah
he had such a flat affect about him he
showed no emotion he was trying so hard
to be polite and cordial
we had a picture made
from our suspect's dna
like those kind of things there
that's not it though
well that's that's the picture we had
created well really yeah
wow
it's kind of
well it looks a lot different to look in
the mirror
something about those composite photos
of the suspected killer seemingly shook
burns as throughout the interview he
keeps on bringing them up
what that's strange those pictures
i know do i look like that
well i kind of think you you do a little
bit
those are the only pictures you had
those those three yeah
you know better than we would if you
look like that in 79.
well i don't think i ever looked like
that
i was a good looking guy if i did
interestingly though after being
presented with a search warrant
never seen all these before
burns seems to have no problem providing
his dna to investigators
during the interview what came across to
me as
him potentially being innocent was the
fact that he was so matter-of-fact and
the police did have a warrant to get his
dna and he signed away and said yeah you
can go ahead and have that so the fact
that he was relaxed to me is
was an initial indicator of the
potential of him not having any part of
it
yet it's at this point when denlinger
changes the conversation
my typical strategy in the interview is
to just let you open up tell me some
sort of story and once i feel like
you've shared about everything you're
going to share with me that's when the
direct confrontation comes
we kind of know going in that this is
probably going to be a match
not really yeah
why would that be
the reality is we're not
we're not here on a whim
we're here to confirm what we already
know
i already collected some dna from you
that you got rid of before
and so i'm telling you jerry i already
know that your
dna is going to match the the dna that
we have on files
how would we get your dna at the crime
scene there jerry
i don't know test it see if it is no no
no we did
he really didn't have an answer for any
of that
he's trying to think
about plausible excuses but he knew
there were none
how would it be there jerry
what happened that night wait for the
test to come back jerry we i don't think
it did it did
i don't think so okay
did you murder someone that night jerry
test the dna
jerry
test the dna
why did this happen jerry
what happened
we kind of assumed we'd get a steady
stream of denials throughout the
interview but we really didn't to me was
quite suspicious i just couldn't figure
out why he wouldn't
slam his hand on the desk and tell me
matter of factly that he didn't kill her
but he never would
coming up burns admits something very
curious
what i don't believe
is that you don't remember being there
that night
if i was there i don't know
what
happened i don't know
you know not there that night
well we know better than that
it's december 19 2018 and iowa
investigators are sitting down with
jerry lynn burns the man they believe
murdered 18 year old michelle martinko
outside of a mall in 1979
after confronting burns with dna
evidence matching him to the crime scene
a result of a technological breakthrough
using genetic genology
burns claims to know nothing about the
killing
we know you were there
but
the why part is
what we're not positive no we better
prove i was there first
well i don't think that's a problem
investigators try to piece together why
burns who had no connection to martinko
would brutally stab her to death
is it possible that you're out at
westdale mall and you run into some some
girl that you feel like talking to or
maybe you you knew casually
is it possible that you just you ran
into her and said hi to her by the you
know
you ever accidentally getting the wrong
car out of west ale mall
no
my personal
theory on what happened that night is i
think jerry was out at west dale mall to
find someone to sexually assault and i
think he picked michelle out at random
when he spotted her walking out to her
car by herself
she started to fight quite a bit
and
in his
panic in the situation he killed her and
and left
burns is later arrested that day which
marked the 39-year anniversary of
michelle's death
burns is placed in a transport cruiser
as he speaks with investigator denlinger
listen to this odd exchange
i think it's possible this happens
i'm sure something like that would be
i just wonder it'd be possible
yeah yeah i think it'd be impossible
to blacked out
i know somebody can block out what's
happening
you think you had a blackout
no i didn't say blackout i said
block things out of your memories oh you
blocked things out i got you
i got you
is it possible that he may have just
blocked out
what happened and he was wondering and
asking the investigator
if that was a possibility and that to me
pointed to him already trying to create
an alibi
or have any any mental episodes in your
life or anything like that where you
can't remember
i don't know
i might have um
no
i can't think of the word where you hit
your head
concussion concussion concussion yeah
probably three or four different times
he started down a road
he's blocked out this murder because it
was traumatic for him too
maybe it was
jerry burns was ultimately charged with
the first degree murder of michelle
martinko
however proving burns as the killer may
not be so straightforward
the perpetrator may very well have been
wearing gloves at the time
they didn't find any latent prints no
fiber evidence no hair evidence that
could be tied back to this individual
specifically
absent an eyewitness to the event it's
very very difficult uh to to peg
somebody down keep in mind we didn't
have cctv back then there was no cell
phone tracking and that sort of thing
when we return burns heads to trial
where some new admissions come to
did you ever ask the defendant directly
if he committed the crime yes i did i
asked him directly
think all court shows are the same we're
talking about your father guilty or not
guilty guilty think again judge caprio
rules with common sense i was having
contractions i was rushing to the
hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre law and crime is
the only network that has it all good
evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't really jump to
conclusions welcome to prime crime
tonight another day of drama between
both sides from multiple live trials
daily to original and compelling
programming the long crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box this is law and crime
after almost 40 years iowa investigators
believe they have finally caught the man
who murdered 18 year old michelle
martinko outside of a mall in 1979
that man
jerry lynn burns
the suspected killer was arrested and
charged with first-degree murder and his
trial began on february 12 2020. the
prosecution relied heavily on genetic
evidence
the suspect male dna profile for
michelle's dress was consistent with the
known dna of the defendant
as well as bern's own strange comments
to law enforcement did you murder
someone that named jerry test the dna
jerry
test the dna
why did this happen jerry
what happened
the defense though jumped on the attack
we cannot conclude that jerry burns's
blood
is the source of the dna on
the dress or the gearshift selector
the prosecution was confronted with the
reality that they had no eyewitnesses no
murder weapon no confession and no
clear-cut motive
yet they did have one more thing for the
jury the testimony of michael allison an
inmate at the same jail as burns
did you ever ask the defendant directly
if he committed the crime yes i did i
asked him directly if
i asked him jerry did you do the crime
and he said i can't talk about this and
he told me that
sometimes he called me son and he said
son he said they might have me but i
don't have to buy my head to him
allison even recalled an eerie remark
burns made when they were playing a game
he had told me if i keep beating him in
pinochle he was going to have to take me
to the mall
after less than four hours of
deliberations the jury returned a
verdict that would provide an answer
almost 40 years in the making
we the jury find the defendant jerry
lynn burns guilty of the charge of
murder in the first degree
there was a little moment there where i
felt the pressure of you know everyone
that had touched this case over 40 years
i knew we weren't going to get another
shot at it
so to get the the guilty verdict i just
took a big sigh and i think i'd stopped
breathing for a little bit and i was
just so relieved
at burn sentencing we heard from one of
the last remaining members of michelle's
family
we are thankful that she fought so hard
michelle played a critical role in
identifying her own killer
the defensive wounds on her hand show it
she fought so hard that she was able to
deflect the killer's knife so that he
stabbed himself
leaving the blood that caught
in a very real way
michelle became her own best witness
still mr jerry burns was clever enough
to steal 39 years of freedom he didn't
deserve
but we also heard from burns himself who
had one final message he wanted to get
out there
first of all i'd like to say that
somebody else stabbed michelle
to death in that car that night i don't
know who i don't know why
i would like to thank my family and
friends for their support
burns can
certainly you know protest his innocence
uh
to the heavens
the problem is this the problem is math
jerry burns's dna was actually
physically found there and at the end of
the day
the chances
that it is him
is one in 100 billion and he can argue
against that all he wants but in the end
science wins
burns was sentenced to life in prison
without the possibility of parole
this this chapter is over we know who
did it
and we know a little bit of
why and that it wasn't one of her
friends who hated her or had a grudge it
was some
impersonal person who had their own
issues
and creep and
killed my sister in this
absolutely horrible way
we still are left with the fact that
we've
lost my sister we've i've lost all of
those years
that she didn't live
and she had such
a bright future and she was looking
forward to college
and we
we lost all of that
jerry lynn burns that's the name that'll
go down as the man who killed an
innocent young woman and remained on the
loose for almost 40 years
however with technological advances like
genetic genealogy
maybe just maybe he'll be one of the
last cold case killers ever again
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
primeprime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe
[Music]
you